finding your data assets is one thing
managing both your technical and
business metadata while maintaining
proper security requirements is a whole
other beast luckily data catalog can
help stay tuned as we cover how to add
schematized tags to your data assets as
well as show you how integration with
cloud Identity and Access Management or
cloud I am provides Alko controls on
your metadata
data catalog is a fully managed and
scalable data discovery a metadata
management service that empowers
organizations to quickly discover
understand and manage all their data in
Google Cloud I am Anita Cuban Gucci and
today we'll be tackling how to
understand your data assets with schema
ties tags in a safe and secure way just
like sticky notes data catalog tags act
as annotations whereas other data
catalogs capture tags as simple text
strings data catalog captures business
metadata in a schematized format via
tags these tags can be created through
the UI as well as custom api's users can
now define a business tag as string
double bullion or enumerated enum making
it easy to catalog and find data assets
so you've heard us talk a lot about
technical and business metadata so what
do we mean by these terms technical
metadata is data that's already saved in
GCP services such as table names column
descriptions and date created this data
is automatically ingested from the data
source into Data catalog without any
involvement on your part for example if
you add a new table to bigquery it will
show up in data catalog in a matter of
seconds on the other hand business
metadata are tags that provide
additional business information that is
valuable to a customer this could
include PII delete by dates business
logic data quality scores as well as
governance tags by adding business
metadata data assets become more
searchable and usable for your team
let's take a look at how you can add
rich information to your data assets
with tag templates on the data catalog
home screen scroll to tag template
section and click on create a tag
templates
here you can define the template ID
display name as well as add attributes
and define their type each attribute
type can be string double boolean or
enum once you've added all your
attributes click on save template
creating a tag templates can also be
done programmatically using custom api's
let's learn more about an existing tag
template on the data catalog home screen
scroll to the tag template section and
click on explore tag templates we'll
look at the data governance tag
templates this template has tags to help
the data governance team certify
specific data assets for use it also
lets approved users know which data
assets they can use you'll notice that
each attribute has a type as well for
data classification the type is enum
from there the data governance team can
now define whether the data asset is
public sensitive confidential or
regulatory and can then apply the
applicable controls around it now that
we've explored a tag template let's look
at how the integration with I am helps
with access control of your data assets
instead of having to set separate
permissions Oracle's to register data
assets data catalog auto ingest tactical
metadata and Ana's existing source code
this means that if a user already has
read access to all data assets in
bigquery then they'll be able to
discover and have read access to those
data assets in data catalog similarly
this I am integration allows further
access controls to be set with data
catalog you can set read access metadata
read-only access and no read or no
metadata read access depending on these
permission settings users search results
and access can be controlled
keeping highly sensitive data limited to
those with the necessary access thanks
for watching and please check out all
our data catalog videos and visit our
website to learn more
you